we've just had the Nobel Prize in
chemistry it was really
exciting because it was leaked
beforehand for the first time ever in
the newspapers before this great meeting
where they reveal the names of the
winners the names were already known I
think though I'm not sure that somebody
sent out a press release too early this
year's Nobel Prize in chemistry you want
to know what it was for and it was for
so-called Quantum dots which are very
very small
particles which have strange properties
you may actually be watching me thanks
to Quantum dots because they're often
used for the colored
pixels on the television screen the red
the green and the blue as usual there
were three Prize winners Louis Bruce who
is at Columbia University in the United
States and Alex Ivanovic yakimov a
Russian who appears to be working now in
the United States and those two
discovered that you could actually make
Quantum dots and the third winner Muni
bendi was the person who found out how
you could make Quantum dots easily and
on a large scale is this a chemistry
Nobel Prize or physics well the people
who got the Nobel Prize are definitely
chemists and a big part of it was the
synthesis of of nanop particles Quantum
dots so yes I guess it should be uh a
Nobel Prize in chemistry could it have
been a Nobel Prize in physics absolutely
are there a lot of physicists who work
in nanop particles and Quantum dots
absolutely including many physicists in
this building Lawrence EES who you've
spoken to many times before Amalia
patani many people in this in this
department work on Quantum dots of
various breeds in various types so yeah
it's welld deserved to the people who
got it is absolutely well deserved are
quantum dots just like Nano particles
are they just small molecules or they
they are small particles of crystalline
materials and the point is that if
they're very
small then Quantum effects change their
properties light propagates in different
ways through the particles so you can
have two particles of the same material
but of different sizes one of which say
fluoresces in the blue and the other in
the red chemically they're identical
just one piece is bigger than the other
piece another word for Quantum dots is
an artificial atom because essentially
although it may comprise hundreds if not
thousands of atoms it acts like one big
atom you're telling me a quantum dot is
bigger than a molecule it's it's a very
very big molecule comprising hundreds
and sometimes thousands of atoms but the
quantum aspect comes from it it's still
pretty small it's really really small
you know this is a whatever number of
atoms we've got in there compared to a
bulk solid which would have 10 to the 23
atoms it's tiny compared to the solid
but the the really neat thing about it
is simply by changing the size you
change the how the electrons behave and
so here's a good example these are gold
nanop particles we've talked about these
on 60 symbols many many years ago and I
had more hair this is gold but you say
but it's red it doesn't look gold and
the reason it looks red is because those
are teeny particles of gold a few
nanometers across and when you make them
that size light interacts with gold the
electrons of gold in a very different
way so it doesn't it loses that gold
Sheen it's not like you'd imagine that's
what the color of gold would be if it
were in solution it's the fact that it's
small and you've changed the frequencies
at which the electrons are moving and
therefore you've changed how they
interact with light hang on are you
drinking the gold
particles yeah we make liters of this
stuff I I I drink it all the time I hope
you're not actually in fact on the west
coast of the US I believe there were
many people who did decide that it was
really good for health reasons to drink
Solutions of gold Nano particles I um
can't commit one way or the other the
Breakthrough by MIM Wendi was to
discover a way of making these it's
really quite simple the way he did it
was to take a very hot liquid and inject
into it a solution which started forming
crystals and because they were all
injected at the same moment all the
crystals started forming at once but
because the liquid going in was cold the
solution cooled down so they didn't grow
very much and then you could warm them
up and get them all to grow just a
little bit more and he chose a liquid
which coated the surface of each
particle so they didn't clamp together
there's a great picture of the website
and these I believe are cadmium selenite
or cadmium sulfide nanop particles the
differences in color you see are just
due to differences in size because by
changing the size of the particles they
change how the electrons are confined
and that changes the energy levels of
the electrons and that changes how they
interact with light the clever thing is
being able to make nanop particles first
of all in a very very well-rolled way so
you can control the the size of them
down to in some cases down to a few
atoms difference it's really very very
neat very very elegant chemistry you can
make nanor rods you can make Branch
things which they call tetrapods you can
bring those together you can assemble
them in different ways and each time
you're doing that you're controlling
what the electrons are doing and
therefore you're getting a huge amount
of functionality out of these so the
thing these people have done basically
is they've just got really good at
making the stuff synthesizing it and and
understanding it I would say it's the
Nobel Prize isn't Just For the synthesis
so that's very important it's also for
the fundamental understanding right in
the early days in the late 70s early '
80s when they were trying to figure this
out they made some really really good
judgments as to the underlying physics
and then being able to control the
chemistry and the physics in concert you
know it's really elegant work thoroughly
deserves the Nobel Prize were these like
famous people who everyone thought was
going to win a Nobel Prize had you heard
of them or is this always a surprise to
you as well well the only person I had
heard of was Louie Bruce who worked in a
similar field to me low temperature
experiments at -
253 centigrade in the late 1960s early
1970s and I think that I actually met
him in his um Lab at the Bell labs in
New Jersey on my first visit to America
50 years ago but we had completely lost
touch and so I was quite excited when I
saw his name on the Nobel Prize I didn't
even know what he'd been doing whether
he was still doing science and so on
Phil I know from working with you over
the years that your science involves
pretty small particles individual atoms
sometimes but you know this this kind of
level is a lot of the work you do
underpinned by what these people did
absolutely um is it related to
absolutely is it much of the same
physics many times it is um so we've got
a new person started hopefully who you
meet in a future 60 symbols or whatever
guy called Brian carali who literally
builds up artificial atoms but on a
Surface so essentially Quantum dots by
moving individual atoms with a scanning
prob microscope on a surface and
confines electrons with a huge amount of
control just by tweaking the position of
the tip sliding these atoms around you
can form uh different structures and
therefore essentially do chemistry with
artificial atoms bring them together
control the spacing of those atoms um so
there are huge links between what we do
what many other nanoscience groups do
and this Nobel Prize in fact as they say
in the press release associated with
this this this led many of the
foundations for
nanoscience after the announcement the
Press of the
winner winners appear on the vi um
satellite link and they're asked
questions and so of course the first
question was did you hear about the leak
but because they were all in America
and they were asleep when the leak
happened they hadn't heard it so they
were woken up by the traditional
telephone call saying that um You've Won
it has struck me that quite often though
not this year the Prize winners say we
got a phone call we thought it was a
hoax but I've never seen any statistics
about how many hoax phone calls there
are to people pretending they've won the
Nobel Prize have you ever got one I
haven't got one but I know it was a
hoax see the link in the video
description for more of our previous
videos about Nobel prizes in chemistry
and while you're there you can also find
a link to what's going on in chemistry
at the University of Nottingham where we
make most of these
videos